the starting pitcher luis castillo who
was set to start yesterday
before rain pushed that home finale
against the pirates to munda he was
straight filthy on friday against the
dodgers you know luis castillo we've
seen the season and you know it
certainly is not how you start it's how
you finish and hopefully this club can
figure out how to get that offense
kicking elaine thomas
sweet ground ball toward third suarez
charges he was playing tight he throws
in time on the run to get lane thomas
for the game's first out and now the
switch hitting josh bell
bell swing sends a high fly ball to
center field playable though pereiro is
back and under it well shy of the track
catch is made escobar is going to tag go
to third throw coming and safe but he
almost threw him out he was very close
to throwing him out it was a two-hop
throw right on target to suarez and
escobar just getting around the tag jose
barrero does a really nice job of
getting behind
that ball in center field
this ball is deep in center field and
you can see him position himself to get
in position to throw that ball if that
ball's on the other side of third base
i think he gets all cd's escobar you
guys make all the plays luis garcia pops
it up
troubled and shallow left coming on
delano to shields to make the catch
here's patrick corbin at two and four
career versus the reds with a four five
three era and nine starts he's two in
one career at this ballpark with 20
strikeouts in just one walk only four
reds in the lineup have faced him before
jonathan india hits it hard two hopper
garcia
little stretch by bell on the throw and
a quick out castianos is having a big
time year
didn't have the sound off the end of the
bat and that's two outs on first pitches
so far runner at first two two two outs
and that'll do it patrick corbin strikes
out joey vado to end the first inning
the nets have first and third for josh
bell turns the count to 2-1
that's pretty solid to left and lane
thomas will score juan soto at two out
base hit bell follows suit josh bell has
driven an 86 one-nothing nets they had
josh fastball up got on top of it going
the other way so he wasn't pitching
around him look at him pull his hands in
fight to get the barrel to the baseball
and upper 90s fastball and puts the nats
up one to nothing that was clutch
all of a sudden corbin loaded the bases
for the dangerous nick castiano's
swing and a miss castellanos eager to
drive in some more runs helping patrick
corbin on two sliders in that advantage
that's a big
pitch to get the second out so the
fastball command just vanished this
ending for whatever reason maybe a
little quick with his delivery not done
yet though
slider that was close
popped up key boom
just out of his reach into the screen it
hit the screen first as angel hernandez
and then into his glove i think they're
gonna check it on i think it was the
right call no good effort by carter wait
a minute that's a catch isn't it i
thought it got the screen just out of
our sight up there that's a hard call
look at angels geez get to climb the
screen wait
this is show it i think that's a catch
where did it hit the screen above it is
that what i'm missing because it's in
his glove
did it ricochet off the screen about a
foot above him and then go into his
glove i think it was several feet above
there i would just like five or six i
would just see if he trapped it against
the net i didn't look above it what a
battle we got going on here with the
bases loaded in two outs
and the pitcher wins the battle
ruiz just steps on home plate for the
force and that's it and not available
breaking ball by patrick corbin when the
slider's good it doesn't matter if it's
lefty or righty from that batter's box
and that's number four tonight there are
times when you're struggling as a hitter
when you're up there and you're saying
you know what i'm going to take a pitch
right here i'm going to see something
that's think something might be up here
how about trying to push a butt for a
hit but corbin a little backhand toss to
bell on a hop
well done for the good athlete bouncing
off the mound yeah when i think about
pitchers i wouldn't but not marcus
strowman comes to my number one i think
patrick corbin's right up there i mean
he's so quick off the mount he's such a
good athlete the backhand shuffle a nice
pick by josh bell when you're a first
baseman it's hard to pick something
without velocity what do i mean by that
it doesn't always stick in your glove
when it's soft and this was kind of
flipped softly
so he had to be aggressive with his
glove to make the ball stick
in there at the end nice play here's
castillo who bunted first time
you can swing it a little bit
and that'll be escobar covering the
ground and lobbing to bell escobar
really had to range a long way to his
left and makes a good play to retire
castillo who was not quite able to sneak
it through the infield so corbin works
out of more trouble pitches around a
lead off walk strands two
juan soto been on base now 25 of his
last 26 games here's the pitch
pretty good sound on a deep one to left
c u
later
it looked like it might have hit the top
of the wall
in the nationals lead do nothing on
soto's 28th mvp why not who's playing
better than juan soto right now nobody
unbelievable what he's done in the month
of september 02 pitch
spread out choked up and he goes the
other way for home run number 28 rbi
number 91 on the season so it is three
and two two outs and the nationals
leading two to nothing in the top of the
seventh here comes juan soda
on a pitch away soto jacks one to left
see
you
later he's done it again are you kidding
me no seriously are you kidding me i
don't even know why i'm surprised i
really don't 29 home runs and the chase
for mvp just got a whole lot closer carp
so three for three
unbased four times two home
runs juan soto ladies and gentlemen in
the great american small park
two taters heads up over there incoming
unbelievable max schrock stands in pinch
hitting for delino de shields the 1-2
pitch
to right field fair ball
suarez through second
soto misses the ball and right suarez
around third truck storms to third base
stop sign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tyler stevenson the rookie catcher now
and he faces finnegan for the first time
two outs
got it with a slider game over and the
nats win it 3-2
you